on est avec thomas 18 ans qui habite en
ardèche dyslexique et dyscalculie c'est
ça mon thomas oui merci d'être là ce
soir vous avez été dit ce qu'elle arrive
et les stories et depuis 2010 9 vous
avez intégré l'epide établissement pour
l'insertion dans l'emploi en mars 2021
et c'est compliqué pour vous
oui énormément l'epide je crois que
c'est quand même pas mal quand même
c'est exceptionnel comme truc parce que
les places se sont assez rares et il n'y
a pas beaucoup de cd d'établissement
pour l'insertion pour ça et c'est vrai
vous comment vous avez connu parce qu'il
ya plein de jeunes règlent ça voilà ça
c'est un truc qu'on connaissait pas
voilà il je collais j'ai connu grâce à
vous et donc c'est bien quand c'est quoi
c'est sur la plateforme à la exact en
voilà donc c'est pour ça que la
plateforme c'est important cependant ce
soir on a fait l'émission aussi pour que
vous alliez sur la plateforme dès ce
soir et que l'on revient d un jeune une
solution point gouv.fr voilà c'est ça va
merci
voilà bah ouais mais c'est vrai que
c'est important alors thomas toi
aujourd'hui c'est pas ton quotidien une
quotidien bain
là en ce moment je suis sur les pid
d'accord au lion et mon quotidien
taperont taperont tu apprends à faire un
métier
peut-être nous apprend déjà loquace mais
on apprend à faire
marcher au pas carré comme les
militaires 6 heures le matin donc on
sait où un déjeuner puis après on doit
faire nous lit au carré
ouais ça rigole pas après ça on doit
définir un petit penco quand même
oui c'est important on va sinon on tient
pas après sandra chocapic je partage
donc bref ça va
après ça on doit faire une nuit de repos
ouais et puis après la journée commence
donc on fait les activités mais je sais
que ton rêve c'est de faire peut-être
dans l'audiovisuel mais montage
caméraman
tu as déjà suivi une formation pour
faire ça ou pas du tout mais pas du tout
tu connais rien avant c'était compliqué
de trouver la passion oui alors moi
malheureusement je connais personne là
dedans non mais c'est vraiment ta
passion tu as envie de films et a envie
de monter bah oui mais ce que j'ai déjà
voilà un passion de base de faire du
montage qui m'est témoin je pars d'un
principe c'est que dans ce métier là la
première chose à voir c'est la passion
si on est passionné par ce métier c'est
sûr qu'on va réussir et qu'on peut
réussir si on a une singularité et on
est passionné par ce métier c'est sûr
qu'on peut réussir en plus c était beau
gosse donc ça n'enlève rien faire non
mais c'est vrai c'est important voilà ce
que je peux proposer c'est d'être ton
mentor mais c'est beaucoup
j'ai aussi proposé d'apprendre je sais
que tu raid être cadreur comme moi là
comme les cadreurs qui sont autour de
cette émission et vachettes proposé
d'apprendre ce métier grâce à ma société
de production h2o productions tu vas
apprendre à cadrer voilà tu viendras
nous voire même pendant l'émission
c'est de te faire des petites est tombé
tu vas être contacté des cadreurs pour
qu'ils apprennent le métier tu vas avoir
un stage qui va commencer en septembre
super voilà donc je serai là merci
beaucoup je sais pas si je suis encore
sur la chaîne mais ma société de
production il sera donc septembre 2021
là ça vous fait rien et après toi
peut-être qu'après ce stage là la
possibilité d'intégrer la rotation des
monteurs présent h2o tu monteras
peut-être les sujets pour touche pas à
mon poste où les usines démontrent bien
ajouter à ces que c'est important que
les jeunes connaissent les pid
moi je suis très sensible à la situation
des jeunes que système scolaire a pas
embarqué il est je pense que c'est
important de leur permettre de rebondir
et je pense que c'est effectivement ce
que ce que vous avez vécu de retrouver
confiance en soi ressasser aussi
fondamentale et peut-être j'avais vu que
vous pensiez coco n'ayant pas le bac
vous ne pouviez pas suivre une formation
dans ce domaine qui vous passionne il ya
des formations bien sûr une très
attentif à proposer des formations
justement aux jeunes qui n'ont pas le
bac
je vais vous dire un truc elisabeth moi
moi j'avais le bac et je voulais faire
une formation aussi d'audiovisuel et je
vous dire c'est que c'est compliqué pour
vais devenir monteur animateurs moi je
me rappelle j'avais passé un test pour
faire une émission pour faire et doit
entrer dans une école j'avais réussi ce
test est finalement ma mère n'a pas pu
m'a dit finalement les c'est trop cher
j'ai pas envie de te l'a payé voilà et
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup d'écoles
privées qui sont très chers et
finalement je rentre en stage voilà et
après bon voila j'ai acheté je cliquais
donc c'est pas envie de payer des écoles
privées très cher il ya des formations
de l'ina institut national de
l'audiovisuel
d'accord c'est le programme alpha qui
permet de découvrir tous les métiers de
l'audiovisuel d'avoir des stages en
entreprise et non seulement ça n'est pas
payant mais quand vous êtes en formation
professionnelle vous êtes rémunéré et on
a revalorisé la rémunération des
stagiaires donc des gens des jeunes qui
sont en formation professionnelle
c'est 500 euros par mois donc tous les
jeunes qui veulent aller qui veulent se
former aux métiers de l'audiovisuel
peut-être si tous ils ont ça va
peut-être faire bourrer les urnes tout
cas via le programme alpha de l'ina il
fait pour mais on apprend voilà on
apprend des trucs qu'on servait pas mal
face à szavay pas ça vous avez parlé de
l'épi tu connaissais pas tout ça et tout
ça s'arrête sur la sur la plate forme il
faut aller voir la plateforme un jeune
une solution
non